[Music]
the story of david and goliath is one of
the most iconic scenes in the bible
armed with nothing but a sling the young
shepherd boy takes down the fearsome
philistine giant although it's a beloved
and popular tale there's one big problem
with it goliath's height you see no can
quite agree on the giant's size
where the bible sees goliath at
approximately 10 feet tall there are
other arguably more plausible sources
that have him a bit shorter at the more
realistic height of about seven feet in
this video let's explore the debates
surrounding the height of the biblical
giant goliath delving into everything
from ancient forms of measurement growth
conditions like gigantism and even a few
biblical typos for good measure as we
ask the question
how tall was goliath
for those unfamiliar with the story of
david and goliath or need a refresher
here's a quick recap
the story takes place during the reign
of king saul who ruled the kingdom of
israel in 11th century bce now things
are not looking good for the nation they
were losing a war against the
philistines a group of people that lived
to the south in modern day gaza
the israelite and philistine armies were
gathering in the valley of ellar
preparing for battle out of the
philistine camp emerge is a huge figure
goliath of gath
every morning and evening he calls out
to the israelite camp demanding a
champion to face him in single combat
the israelites desperately looked
amongst each other then looked towards
their king but he was too afraid to step
forward each day the giant repeated his
demand and each day no one agreed to
fight him that is until one day when a
shepherd boy david overhears goliath and
plans to step forward despite having no
military experience he approaches the
israelite army and king saul hurriedly
accepts his request to fight the giant
the king offers the boy his armor but is
too heavy and david rejects it instead
he grabs his sling and selects five
smooth stones from a nearby stream
putting them in his pouch
david passes to the israelite ranks to
meet goliath the giant laughs and says
quote am i a dog that you come to me
with sticks come to me i will give your
flesh to the birds of the air and to the
wild animals of the field
the philistines start laughing and curse
the god of israel unfazed dave responds
with this famous line this very day the
lord will deliver you into my hand and i
will strike you down and cut off your
head for the battle is the lord's and he
will give you into our hand
with that david loads a small stone in
his sling and launches it at goliath the
stone strikes him square between the
eyes killing him instantly
david approaches the body and removes
the head displaying it to the horrified
philistine army dismayed the philistines
retreat and their camp is plundered by
the israelites david returns to king
saul proudly holding up the head of the
conquered philistine champion
the story marks the beginning of david's
rise to power and highlights just how
unfit king saul is to rule soon david
will replace saul as the rightful king
of israel
if you open a copy of the bible you'll
find the story in the first book of
samuel chapter 17 scroll down to verse 4
and it will describe the giant goliath
as six cubits and a span
qubits and spans are units of length
pioneered by the egyptians who use them
when building the pyramids one cubit is
the distance from your elbow to your
middle finger a span is about half that
measuring from the tip of the little
finger to the tip of the thumb when the
hand is fully stretched out confusing i
know but for most of human history the
human body was used for all kinds of
measurements you still get remnants of
this today especially in the old english
imperial system where things are still
measured in feet legend has it that king
henry viii shoe size 12 inches was the
basis for today's foot and an inch was
apparently defined by king david the
first of scotland who used the width of
his thumb as the standardized
measurement
it's all terribly complicated and you
can see where the french designed the
beautifully logical metric system that
divided everything into neat multiples
of 100
back to our qubits and spans one of the
big problems about measuring things this
way is that everyone's arms and hand
sizes are a bit different a qubit of a
tool person is different to that of a
small person for the sake of argument
many biblical scholars have standardized
one cubit into 18 inches a span is about
half of that so that's 9 inches
doing the maths now we are told that
goliath was six cubits and a span he
would therefore measure out to a
monstrous nine foot nine inches
that is very big far bigger than the
tallest human ever recorded robert
wadlow of the us who reached an altitude
of 8 foot 11 inches as with many of the
tallest people who have lived is often
the result of certain growth disorders
gigantism is a condition when the human
body over produces a certain hormone
required for growth conveniently known
as growth hormone this hormone is
produced in the pituitary gland which
can be found at the base of the brain
for a typical person it will secrete
throughout childhood increase during
puberty and then cease into early
adulthood gigantism however is often
caused when this gland is obstructed by
a brain tumor causing rapid and extreme
growth throughout one's life when humans
get to that kind of height a number of
problematic health conditions emerge
maintaining such a large body puts
massive strain on the bones and the
heart people with gigantism often
require specialized crutches and also
suffer from intense headaches fatigue
and lack of vision from the decreased
circulation it's the reason why robert
wadlow the tallest man to have lived
only reached the age of 22 returning to
goliath measuring at nine foot nine
inches would have put extreme pressure
on his body due to the structure and
density of human bones he simply would
not have been able to stand upright with
such mobility issues it's doubtful that
he would have made such a good warrior
as depicted in the bible story
now goliath isn't the only giant in the
bible in fact there's a whole slew of
them some of whom may even be his
ancestors
to explore this issue i've roped in a
fellow creator toasters who's also been
helping me edit this video
in the book of genesis we are introduced
to the nephilim who are the cursed
offspring of humans and angels
the nephilim appear again in the book of
numbers where they are described as
being so tall that normal humans look
like grasshoppers in comparison
if we take that literally and scale it
up that would mean they'd be about the
size of the statue of liberty there are
actually plenty of other giants in the
old testament like the refame the
zamsumin and the anakim in the book of
joshua we are told this last group of
giants the anakim settled in gaza in the
philistine city of goth and you know who
else came from goth goliath it may
explain his great height as the size of
a person is greatly influenced by one's
genetics at the same time height-related
disorders like gigantism are also known
to pass down through families elsewhere
in the bible we learn that goliath has a
brother lami who is also a giant some
have seen this as proof of gigantism in
the goliath's family but who knows it's
all little speculative but an
interesting detail nonetheless
if we assume goliath existed and that he
really was nine foot nine inches we are
dealing with the tallest person in
history but if we consider the health
realities facing goliath it is highly
unlikely that he would ever have been
able to be a warrior perhaps then the
story is not meant to be taken literally
or scientifically accurate instead it
could just be artistic license
exaggerating the height of this mythical
warrior there's another alternative
though his massive height may have been
an error in the transmission of the text
you may already be aware that the bible
was not written in one go instead it
developed over a period of a thousand
years and was written by numerous people
all from different walks of life even a
single book would have been authored by
many hands developing organically over
time as bits were added and other bits
were taken away in the ancient world
early drafts copies and manuscript
fragments were passed around from scribe
to scribe so you'd even get different
versions of the bible depending on where
you'd go the version of the old
testament that we've got today is called
the masoretic text which belonged to a
jewish sect called the mazarites who
lived from the 7th to 10th centuries ce
that's ce not bce so pretty late in the
great scheme of things well into the
medieval era there are way older
versions of the bible out there the most
famous of which is a greek translation
of the old testament called the
septuagint this version was written in
egypt somewhere around the 3rd to the
2nd centuries bce which places it much
more in our time frame
if you turn to the story of david and
goliath in this older greek version it
offers a different height instead of six
qubits and a span he's now four cubits
and a span doing the maths again that
puts him at the height of six foot nine
inches
six foot nine is nothing to be laughed
at that's tool by anyone's standards
especially as the average height of an
israelite man living in this period was
probably about five foot people were
smaller back then at six foot nine
goliath would have been the same height
as the icelandic strongman hathor
bjornsson who rose to international fame
by playing the mountain in game of
thrones while six foot nine is very tall
it's not gigantism tall it's a height
attainable without the various hormone
imbalances that can lead to gigantism
the advantage being is that there are no
associated health risks at this height
and so the giant goliath may very well
have been a great fighter as the bible
suggests just ask the two-time world
heavyweight champion tyson fury who also
stands at six foot nine
this greek version of the text seems
promising measuring at six foot nine and
not at nine foot nine goliath's height
would have been not only more realistic
but would have meant that he'd been a
better warrior free from the various
health complications that faced some of
the tallest people to have ever lived
all this begs the question why does our
version of the bible have such a big
goliath how did he grow from the
original height of four qubits in a span
all the way to six qubits and a span
there are a bunch of theories here some
say it's embellishment others say it's
the original version but there's one
that stands out as being the most
plausible
what is believed to have happened with
goliath is that a scribe may have
accidentally changed his height this
likely could have happened when their
eye drifted across the page whilst
copying the text and writing a part of
it out wrong this was an easy mistake to
make the hebrew word for qubit looks
like this
it appears in verse 4 where it talks
about goliath's height
now a few lines later in verse 7 when it
discusses the weight of glass spear it
has the number 600 as in the spear
weighed 600 shekels
the hebrew word for qubit looks
remarkably similar to the hebrew number
100 just the letters are in a different
order the scribe could have been looking
at the number 6 whilst writing out the
amount of qubits originally 4 it
wouldn't take much to slip and whoops
four qubits becomes six cubits and
goliath grows two cubits this new height
is in the version of the bible that
we've inherited today most likely
through the latin translation although
all this sounds a bit silly this is
actually a very well documented
phenomenon in biblical studies and it
happens more than you'd think this
wandering eye has a fancy academic name
parablepsis a greek word literally
meaning looking by the side i've even
done a video on this kind of thing
examining the many often amusing scribal
errors found in the bible
to recap it all many believe that
goliath was not the absurdly tall 9 foot
9 but the more realistic height of six
foot nine this shorter height is
preserved in the oldest versions of the
biblical texts
somewhere down the line gillard's height
may have been changed by accident this
could have occurred when the story was
copied out by hand remember this was way
before the printing press so everything
had to be painstakingly written out
imagine for a moment copying out the
bible yourself you're bound to make some
mistakes
whatever his actual height may have
really been if he even existed goliath
is synonymous with big things
particularly animals from the largest
tarantula the goliath bird eater to the
namesake of the world's largest species
of frog
his confrontation and fall to the future
king david is the stuff of legend and is
one of the most iconic scenes in
biblical mythology
like david we've taken goliath down to
size but in this case
quite literally
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this one if you'd like to
see more why not subscribe a like and a
comment also go a really long way
and also many thanks to toasters for
helping me out with this video and doing
that little segment earlier on i
recommend you check out his channel he
covers a number of topics you might like
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye
[Music]